und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend israel bot beim thema kroner ja
schon häufiger anschauungsunterricht
etwa wie schnell es gehen kann was man
von niedrigen instanzen plötzlich wieder
in eine neue welle rauscht israelische
virologen warnten damals auch macht
nicht die gleichen fehler wie wir sie
impften dann aber auch schneller als
andere so konnte man die wirksamkeit der
bayern tag impfungen dort gut beobachten
jetzt aber auch wie sich die delta
variante auswirken könnte das
israelische gesundheitsministerium
jedenfalls sieht hinweise dass der
impfstoff gegen diese mutante deutlich
schwächer wirkt es gibt in der hinsicht
aber auch hoffnungsvolles zu berichten
michael lieferungen mit den einzelheiten
er ist nur ein kleines teil der großen
impf maschinerie israels der wartesaal
der im station von ramat hasharon ein
vorort von tel aviv
und doch wird hier im minuten-takt
geimpft fast ausschließlich kinder und
jugendliche auch wie von seiner
schwester warten die meisten der über 16
jährigen hat israel in einem nationalen
kraftakt geimpft jetzt sind die zwölf
bis 15 jährigen dran
sie gelten als schlüssel zur eindämmung
der delta variante die hier alle anderen
corona varianten fast vollständig
verdrängt hat und jetzt vor allem bei
den jungen grassiert
oft könnten corona kranke in meiner nähe
sein erklärt aviv und ich möchte mich
schützen wir waren nicht begeistert die
kinder impfen zu lassen aber die sorge
vor quarantäne und vor den verschiedenen
symptomen wie longo wird bei kindern von
denen wir gehört haben haben uns stress
gemacht wir wollten das vermeiden
jetzt fehlen nur noch die allerjüngsten
doch für kinder unter zwölf jahren gibt
es noch keine zulassung
wir können keine herdenimmunität
erreichen ohne alle kinder zu impfen das
ist sehr schwierig wenn nicht unmöglich
jetzt sind die jugendlichen an der reihe
aber genauso wichtig ist dass bis
oktober november die zulassung zu
bekommen auch die kinder zu impfen
könnte die delta variante an den strich
durch diese rechnung machen meldungen
über eine deutlich gesunkene
effektivität des bayern tech wirkstoffs
verunsichern sagt der schutz vor
infektionen im februar noch bei über 95
prozent sank er mit delta auf 64 im juni
vor schwerer erkrankungen schützte
bayern tech gar fast hundertprozentig
jetzt immerhin noch zu 93 prozent
dr schacher findet solche zahlenspiele
irreführend die korona impfung sei eine
einzigartige erfolgsgeschichte
wir sind soweit bei der impfung nach nur
anderthalb jahren mit unglaublichen
quoten 94 95 prozent schutz vor tod oder
schwere erkrankungen das ist
wissenschaft at its best agers these
scheint sich zu bestätigen während die
tägliche infektionsrate gestern um 50%
auf 500 hochschnellte sterben nur ganz
wenige auch die zahl der schweren fälle
die kaum gestern sank sie sogar um 2 auf
allerdings steigt die zahl der
vollständig geimpften wenn auch meist
ohne symptome positiv getestet werden
dass sie andere anstecken können ist
belegt allerdings wohl nur in geringerem
ausmaß sagen nicht nur experten in
israel die zahlen aus israel und aus
schottland zeigen dass man auch als
doppelt geimpfter noch virus auf den
schleimhäuten tragen kann
ob dieses virus tatsächlich noch so
ansteckend es wie es von jemandem der
nicht geimpftes ist ist nicht klar
denn der gamestar hat ihr antikörper und
die setzten sich sofort auf dieses virus
drauf und reduzieren natürlich auch
dessen ansteckungsfähigkeit die menschen
werden weiter mit dem virus leben müssen
und dem kampf gegen roh sigma tau oder
wie auch immer künftige varianten heißen
mögen mit impfung und mit maske aus den
israelischen erfahrungen zu lernen
könnte unter anderem bedeuten dass sich
politik und verwaltung hierzulande jetzt
intensiv gedanken machen wie die schulen
bis zum ende der sommerferien sicherer
gemacht werden zumal ihm versichert wird
man wolle schulen auf keinen fall
nochmal schließen und auch kein wechsel
unterricht mehr da wäre es natürlich
schön wenn man in diesem herbst nicht
wieder über die versäumnisse des sommers
klagen müsste das hatten wir ja schon
mal altbekannte vorschläge und
forderungen was zu tun wäre liegen auf
dem tisch
allerdings wird über sinn und zweck
einzelner maßnahmen auch weiterhin
gestritten
roters spiekermann berichtet
bundeskanzlerin merkel sagt es
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen sagt es
auch präsenzunterricht nach den
sommerferien hat höchste priorität so
weit dass politische wollen
in der realität hat allerdings das
schwarze-peter-spiel konjunktur
es geht um luftfilter in klassenräumen
wer soll sie bezahlen
der lehrer verband schätzt dass bis zum
herbst bundesweit nur zehn prozent der
schulen mit stationären oder mobilen
raumluft filtern ausgestattet sein
werden man könnte direkt von einem déjà
vu erlebnis versprechen auch im letzten
sommer waren die inzidenz zahlen sehr
niedrig haben die kultusminister in fast
allen ländern ein ende der pandemie
verkündet vollen unterrichtsbetrieb im
herbst und wir sind dann in die zweite
welle gelaufen ohne dass die schulen
darauf vorbereitet worden
es gibt zwar inzwischen förderprogramme
von bund und ländern
doch es hakt gewaltig der bund etwa
bezuschusst stationäre fest eingebaute
raum filteranlagen viele klamme kommunen
zögern wegen der hohen gesamtkosten
einige länder fördern auch mobile geräte
deren nutzen aber umstritten ist
wir sind glaube ich gut beraten
auf das natürliche umfeld zu achten auf
die hygiene zu achten und auf frische
luft zu achten
und dann kann ergänzend sowas eingesetzt
werden ganz und gar abladen möchten wir
von mobilen lösungen die nur lärm machen
und in der tat nur sehr bedingt geeignet
sind die luft zu filtern
stimmt nicht sagt ein führender forscher
wenn man einen entsprechenden hohen
luftfluss hat in den luftfiltern dann
reduzieren sie dass er so zum beispiel
in einem klassenraum sehr gut man kann
in einer halben stunde 90 prozent der
eurozone loswerden und hat dann wenn
diese ihre sohle virus haltig sind auch
eine entsprechende reduktion des
infektionsrisikos eine berufsbildende
schule in hannover hier fährt man
zweigleisig natürliches lüften durch
offene fenster und seit neuestem raum
luftfilter mobile geräte kosten zwischen
300 und 4000 euro
das land niedersachsen unterstützt
schauen wir mal was nach den ferien
delta mit uns macht aber ich glaube wir
sind an der stelle gut gerüstet und sind
froh und glücklich dass unser
schulträger und diese möglichkeit
gegeben hat ich finde es ist eine gute
möglichkeit da man hier ja die fenster
nicht komplett öffnen kann
das einzige was halt wir sind störend
ist es dass so ein ganze zeit und
leichtes unterschiedliches brummen zu
hören ist aber so im unterrichts
gespräch kann man das eigentlich gut
ausblenden das hätte ruhig noch
schneller kommen können und dass muss
nach flächendeckender passieren viel
zeit verstreicht jetzt ungenutzt in
vielen schulen passiert im moment nichts
ist droht wieder stoßlüften bei
minustemperaturen ohne raum filter es
droht im schlimmsten fall wieder
unterricht auf distanz zur debatte
darüber welche maßnahmen gegen korona
wie lange noch nötig sein werden
finden sie bei uns auch online videos
und hintergründe auf zdf wollte und
jetzt die nachrichten als wolf die
zukunftskommission landwirtschaft
empfiehlt einen massiven umbau des agrar
und energie sektors das gremium mir
begabter und zehnmonatigen beratungen
bundeskanzlerin merkel ihren
abschlussbericht damit die
landwirtschaft nachhaltiger werden
müssten unter anderem die preise für
agrarprodukte erhöht und der
fleischkonsum reduziert werden zudem
sollten förderungen für landwirte und
umwelt
und klimapolitische kriterien geknüpft
werden
tag 2 für das niederländische königspaar
in berlin auf dem terminplan standen
heute weitere politische gespräche am
vormittag wurden willem alexander und
maxima im wald tags gebäude empfangen
inklusive einer führung durch die kuppel
nach einem gespräch mit abgeordneten
hielt der könig dann noch eine rede im
bundesrat dabei rief zum gemeinsamen
kampf gegen den klimawandel
im anschluss begrüßte angela merkel das
paar im bundeskanzleramt am abend stand
dann noch ein konzertbesuch mit
bundespräsident steinmeier auf der
agenda
die us streitkräfte haben ihren abzug
aus afghanistan zu mehr als 90 prozent
abgeschlossen das teilte das pentagon in
washington mit beobachter befürchten
dass die taliban die in einigen
landesteilen auf dem vormarsch sind
wieder die macht übernehmen könnten nach
dem vollständigen abzug der nato
streitkräfte
das afghanische verteidigungsministerium
kündigte heute eine gegenoffensive gegen
die taliban im norden des landes an
beim absturz einer passagiermaschine im
osten russlands sind wahrscheinlich alle
28 menschen an bord ums leben gekommen
trümmer des flugzeugs seien nahe dem
zielflughafen planer auf der halbinsel
kamtschatka gefunden worden teilte die
russische luftfahrtbehörde mit die
maschine befand sich bei schlechtem
wetter im landeanflug als sie vom radar
verschwand bergiges gelände erschwert
die arbeit der such und rettungskräfte
kommen wir zum schwierigsten teil der
heutigen sendung schon über den
missbrauchsfall münster journalistisch
zu berichten fällt schwer da will man
sich erst recht nicht ausmalen was
ermittler staatsanwälte und richter im
zuge der beweisaufnahme alles zu sehen
bekam
es muss weit über die grenzen des
erträglichen hinausgegangen seien zwei
richtern brach bei der urteilsverkündung
heute die stimme auch ist das
videomaterial so umfangreich das schiere
ausmaß so gigantisch dass sich allein
das eigentlich kaum fassen lässt
es gibt offenkundig einen großen markt
dafür mit vielen personen die gerne
dafür zahlen
um sich anzusehen wie sadisten kinder
quellen ralph goldmann berichtet es ist
juni 2020 als das technische hilfswerk
eine laube in der kleingartenanlage
nördlich von münster abreißt um noch
letzte versteckte beweismittel zu finden
die ermittler haben tage zuvor
massenhaft datenträger und einen server
raum entdeckt mit fotos und videos von
sexualisierter gewalt an betreuten
kindern die erfahrene beamte fassungslos
machen
vier erwachsene männer vergeben sich an
zwei kleine news wechselseitig und aufs
schlimmste
es werden gegenstände benutzt sie können
sich jetzt nicht vorstellen
fassungslosigkeit und entsetzen auch
heute im gerichtssaal teilweise lachen
und grinsen die angeklagten beim
urteilsspruch dem vorsitzenden richter
matthias pfeiler versagt dabei fast die
stimme angesichts der unerträglichen
bilder die die kammer sich anschauen
musste das gericht hat sehr deutlich
gemacht dass sich an diesen tagen
grauenhafte szenen ereignet haben müssen
selbst für solch erfahrene berufsrichter
die wiederholt und immer wieder mit
solchen fällen beschäftigt sind wurden
die grenzen des vorstellbaren bei weitem
überschritten
der it techniker adlern v 28 jahre wird
zu 14 jahren haft mit anschließender
sicherungsverwahrung verurteilt wegen
schweren sexuellen missbrauchs
vergewaltigung und gefährlicher
körperverletzung drei weitere männer
müssen zwischen zehn und zwölf jahre in
haft
auch sie danach in sicherungsverwahrung
carina fadri als mutter hatte die
schlüssel der laube zur verfügung
gestellt im wissen was dort passieren
würde
sie muss wegen beihilfe fünf jahre in
haft noch sind die urteile nicht
rechtskräftig bei den ermittlungen
stellte sich heraus das ist nur die
spitze des eisbergs 29 kinder fielen
offenbar 50 tatverdächtigen zum opfer 30
sitzen in untersuchungshaft 7 sind
bereits verurteilt in der
asservatenkammer der münsteraner polizei
stapeln sich computer und festplatten
wir haben ungefähr die hälfte der
asservate ausgewertet und ungefähr die
hälfte nicht nur für uns wobei wir
natürlich nicht wissen
wenn wir einerseits anfassen was da
drauf ist es ist meine box der pandora
die wieder öffnen
und wir wissen nicht wie viel
strafrechtlich bewährtes material dort
zu finden ist der münsteraner der fall
ist nach denen auf einem campingplatz in
lüfter im kreis lippe und bergisch
gladbach bei köln bereits der dritte
einer ganzen serie von missbrauchs kommt
echsen in nordrhein westfalen seit 2009
der innenminister hat das thema zur
chefsache erklärt das personal im
vergleich zu 2008 10 vervierfacht wir
machen mehr
wir haben eine bessere technologie wir
machen viel mehr geld investiert 33
millionen mittlerweile daran wir haben
alle diese polizeistation die am thema
abend verletzt
so kommen jetzt immer mehr fälle ans
tageslicht die aufklärungsquote liegt
bei fast 90 prozent mehr kinder werden
gerettet und mehr täter verurteilt
er wütet und tobt gegen jeden der ihm in
die quere kommt der belarussische
diktator lukaschenko hatte sich ja
bereits mit der gesamten europäischen
staatengemeinschaft angelegt als ja ein
passagierflugzeug quasi entführen ließ
um einen regimekritiker verhaften zu
können
für die sanktionen die das zur folge
hatte will er sich nun auch noch rächen
lukaschenko kündigte an er werde
flüchtlinge zum beispiel aus afghanistan
durchwinken und in die eu schicken an
der grenze zu litauen lässt sich das
auch schon beobachten
außerdem droht er den europäischen
warenverkehr durch sein land zu stoppen
indem das am ende mehr schadet wird man
sehen
schlimmer ist wie er gegen seine
kritiker im eigenen land vorgeht heute
ließ er den führenden
oppositionspolitiker des landes
verurteilen
christian senn berichtet 21 jahre lang
hatte elena karachi war zusammen mit
victor barcot gearbeitet erst als
sekretärin dann als seine persönliche
assistentin als baba ricoh seine
politische kampagne startete je länger
ist stolz auf die wenigen briefe die sie
sich mit ihrem chef viktor der im
gefängnis sitzt schreiben kann
auch wenn ihn nicht alle briefe
erreichten sagt lehner
ich kann aus seinen briefen und aus
seiner reaktion im gerichtssaal sehen
das eher fröhlich und optimistisch ist
und dass er die situation um ihn herum
führt
er rechnet nicht mit einem wunder und
hat sich auf einen marathon eingestellt
wie er selbst sagt dieser marathon
beginnt für victor barcot im letzten
jahr als aussichtsreicher kandidat
wollte der ex bankier bei den
präsidentschaftswahlen in belarus gegen
machthaber lukaschenko antreten
doch im juni 2020 die festnahme sieben
wochen vor der wahl schaltet lukaschenko
seinen politischen widersacher aus heute
das erwartet harte urteil in einem
prozess den nicht nur bei ricoh für
politisch inszeniert hält 14 jahre haft
wegen angeblicher geldwäsche bestechung
und steuerhinterziehung
das heute gefällte urteil gegen bubba
ricco war absolut vorhersehbar
es passt so logik der behörden gegner
und zivilgesellschaft zu unterdrücken
das sehen wir seit einem jahr victor
barcot ist ein prominentes aber bei
weitem nicht das einzige opfer im system
der willkür gewalt und repressionen von
diktator lukaschenko als baba rico im
august 2020 nicht zur wahl antreten
konnte sprang seine wahlkampf managerin
maria callas nie koffer ein
zusammen mit svetlana tier an oskar
ebenfalls präsidentschaftskandidatin und
veronika sepp carlo kämpften drei frauen
für ein freies belarus ohne lukaschenko
hunderttausende folgten ihnen auf den
straßen
sap carlo und tier an oskar mussten weg
aus belarus maria kulissen die koffer
sitzt seit zehn monaten im gefängnis
opposition und proteste kaltgestellt und
niedergeknüppelt
von lukas schenkel heute kein kommentar
zur abba rico er drohte lieber europa
wegen der sanktionen massenhaft
geflüchtete aus afghanistan syrien und
dem irak nach europa durch zu lassen
zu prozessbeginn machte lukaschenko klar
was er von baba rico hält alle machen so
einen rummel gegen bubba rico acht mann
hat den konkurrenten des präsidenten
eingesperrt auch solche konkurrenten
pfeife ich elena kagawa barrios
assistentin saß im letzten jahr selbst
zwei monate in einem geheimdienst
gefängnis wegen angeblicher
steuervergehen
sie sagt barbara kusey lukaschenko
gefährlich geworden weil er anders sei
er aber den menschen hoffnung
auf ein ganz anderes leben gegeben mit
hans wolf und den nachrichten aus der
wirtschaft geht's weiter
da gilt ein besonders aufmerksamer blick
der zeit der entwicklung beim ölpreis
der ist weiter nach oben gegangen und
das beschäftigt nicht nur die autofahrer
wegen der spritpreise valerie haller
welche bedeutung hat der ölpreis
insgesamt für die wirtschaft also das
wirkt fast schon wie eine weltweite
steuer erhöhungen öl steckt ja in so
vielem die industrie braucht es für ihre
fabriken privatleute zum heizen und
tanken
die chemische industrie für ihre
produkte die logistik für den
warentransport ein dauerhaft hoher
ölpreis hat daher auch das potenzial die
inflation anzuheizen und letztlich die
welt konjunktur abzuwürgen
grund für die jüngste preisrallye sind
die geplatzten opec verhandlungen
das kartell ringt um einen deal aber
blockiert sich selbst was sonst hinter
geschlossenen türen passiert tragen
saudi arabien und die vereinigten
arabischen emirate offen aus ihr krach
ist der grund warum sich die opec auf
höhere förderquoten nicht einigen kann
als klar war dass die gespräche
gescheitert waren machte der ölpreis
einen weiteren satz nach oben die beiden
wichtigsten ölsorten kräftig im plus so
hoch wie seit jahren nicht an der börse
geht wegen des teuren öls die angst vor
höherer inflation um der dax kommt
spürbar unter druck
ob das schwarze gold dauerhaft so teuer
bleibt ist keine ausgemachte sache gut
möglich dass einzelne länder aus dem
kartell ausscheren und mehr produzieren
als sie eigentlich dürfen solange die
blockade in der opec anhält denn der
hohe ölpreis könnte für einige
förderländer einfach zu verlockend sein
denn da winken eben auch höhere gewinne
ballaballa vielen dank mit dem beginn
der neuen bundesliga-spielzeit 2021/22
könnte die zeit der geisterspiele vorbei
sein
von der politik kommt grünes licht für
die rückkehr der fans in die stadien
laut eines beschlusses der chefinnen und
chefs der staats und senatskanzleien
dürfen die stadien für sportliche
großveranstaltungen unter bestimmten
voraussetzungen künftig wie dazu maximal
ausgelastet werden bei einer obergrenze
von 25.000 dem stadion in bayern müssten
20.000 beim tennis-turnier in wimbledon
hat angelique kerber das halbfinale
erreicht dort trifft sie am donnerstag
auf die weltranglisten-erste erstellbar
die aus australien ihr viertelfinal
spiel heute gegen carolina moore war aus
tschechien gewand kerber in zwei sätzen
strahlendes lächeln nach ganz reife
leistung je länger die partie dauerte
desto mehr zermürbt der angelique kerber
carolina moro war vor allem dank ihrer
starken rückhand imponierte die
33-jährige mit direkten gewinnschlägen
aber auch läuferisch und über kopf eine
nahezu perfekte vorstellung der
deutschen extrem frustrierend für ihre
24 jährige tschechische gegnerin körper
zum vierten mal im wimbledon halbfinale
6 2 und 6 3
die filmfestspiele von cannes sind
erfüllt und zwar nicht digital sondern
ganz real mit echten roten teppichen und
echten stars und sternchen die vor
leibhaftigen fotografen posieren die
rückkehr zur normalität ist das ereignis
letztes jahr war kann ja ganz abgesagt
worden in diesem jahr wurde es dann in
den juli verschoben
was soll auch eine gute idee waren im
mai waren die instanzen in frankreich
noch sehr viel höher als jetzt
das filmfestival gilt nun auch als eine
art test versuch es ist das erste
richtig große kulturereignis in
frankreich und ein hoffnungsvolles
zeichen für die weltweit gebeutelte
kinobranche thomas walde ist für uns an
der côte d'azur helen mirren andie
macdowell jessica chastain pedro
almodóvar jodie foster und viele mehr
der rote teppich entfernt war es beinahe
vor bekannten namen als wolle man die
zwangspause wett machen das leben
nachholen
als solle kern zum symbol werden des
neubeginns weit über die branche und die
côte d'azur hinaus
wo tatjana hat sich per e-mail hierher
eingeladen wurde fragte ich mich ob das
festival wohl stattfindet angesichts der
gefahr durch die pandemie dass wir alle
heute hier sind grenzt an ein wunder
wir realisieren wohl erst jetzt was wir
ein besonderer moment das ist mit diesem
sehr speziellen festival bei einer
historisch mit großen worten mit großen
gesten haben sie hier nie gespart aber
jetzt tragen sie noch ein bisschen
kinder auf kann verweist darauf dass
seine jury als erster eines großen
festivals mehr frauen als männer zähle
und als erstes an den schwarzen künstler
zum vorsitzenden habe der antwortet
angemessen kann ist das bedeutendste
festival der welt das soll andere jetzt
nicht herabsetzen weg in ihre oma sro
kann und cupid küsschen waren auf dem
roten teppich nicht erlaubt ein
testzentrum für die teilnehmer
verspricht schnelle ergebnisse das
festival selbst zum testlauf zu werden
für das leben nach der pandemie
statt über das virus will man nun über
den wettbewerb reden
den eröffnete annähert einer der 24
filme die um die goldene palme ringen
eine musik komödie mit dem driver und
marion cotillard mich ist sie war ein
festival mit diesem film zu eröffnen der
schon in seiner ersten szene den
zuschauer einlädt mit zu feiern und
einem spektakel beizuwohnen das ist
perfekt dieses festival mit dem film zu
eröffnen an dem wir sieben jahre
gearbeitet haben bedeutet zugleich eine
erleichterung und aufregung letizia
material macht kleines kino das kleinste
in cannes drei säle frau maria freut
sich dass es beim großen nachbarn
nebenan wieder losgeht das sei gut für
alle
das festival macht wieder lust auf kino
das weckt die lebensgeister der
kinofreunde für uns ist das ein
aushängeschild für die arbeit die wir
hier machen und für unsere
wiedereröffnung
so steht die branche zusammen stärkt
sich gegenseitig und entdeckt das eigene
medium wie der neu heute abend setzt
sich zum ersten mal seit 15 monaten in
einem kino das gilt auch für mich kann
die côte d'azur das kino heute am späten
abend urlauber sind eingeladen zu
öffentlichen vorführungen und damit
schreibt am ende das leben selbst die
schönste geschichte einfach dadurch dass
das kino für alle wieder da ist
das was wir uns zu dieser späten stunde
es lohnt sich aber noch etwas länger
wach zu bleiben denn gleich geht es bei
markus lanz weiter er debattiert mit
seinen gästen heute über fußball krone
und mike ab und um 0.55 gibt es dann die
nächste heute express und uns morgen
wieder in der halbzeitpause ist daher
wieder sehen sind
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter in skandinavien
gab es in den letzten tagen rekordhitze
oder erneut steigen die temperaturen bis
zu 30 grad an
bei uns wird es etwas kühler hier fließt
kühlere luft ein
und das sehen wir hier auf unserem
vorschau film sehen hier wie die hitze
weiter in den norden transportiert wird
das hoch blockiert den weg der tief so
kann das tief gar nicht weiter weg und
bei uns eben die kühlere luft die
kommenden stunden wird es unwetter geben
im süden heftiger starkregen in der nähe
von gewittern teils mit habe und das
auch im osten deutschlands sonst lockert
es im westen auf und dort temperaturen
bis neun grad zb der eifel ansonsten im
osten werte um die 18 grad marke so
ziemlich mit morgen am vormittag im
osten noch viele wolken mit regen
genauso im süden westen viel
sonnenschein zwischen emsland und
nordsee zum nachmittag lockert es dann
auch in den östlichen landesteilen auf
auch im süden einige schauer unter im
tagesverlauf bilden sich ganz im norden
dann einige gewitter an der nordsee aber
dazwischen immer wieder sonnenschein bei
temperaturen bis 26 grad im osten und in
bayern am kühlsten bleibt es am
alpenrand mit 20 grad